a mass investor Exodus from crypto in
general is it possible our disheveled
villain killed the Golden Goose joining
me now to discuss cryptocurrency expert
and author of undressing Bitcoin Leia
heilpern joins me now Leia welcome to
the show
thanks for having me great to be here so
this guy wrecked a bunch of people's
lives it looks like he stole a bunch of
money from FTX to prop up uh his other
failing business he doesn't have any
remorse he's pleading ignorance that
doesn't sit well with people who've lost
their life savings potentially so what
does Justice look like for this jerk
well right now Justice doesn't look like
it's coming anytime soon obviously we
saw today he was speaking at the New
York Times Summit where it was very much
um it wasn't a very serious situation at
all we could see you know he lied he
made some jokes he received a round of
applause afterwards and also you just
have to look at um the people that are
involved with FTX I mean Sam Bachman
freed was one of the second largest
donors to Biden's um to President
Biden's campaign he had the likes of
Bill Clinton and Tony Blair speaking his
conference down in the Bahamas so I'm
not feeling very confident that um he
will see the true weight of um of the
law even the New York Times are creating
all these puff pieces about him Forbes
and we're glorifying him it's very
bizarre and unfortunately I don't think
he's gonna um see real Justice it's
really interesting because he was
propping up the Democrat Party
essentially but he people who were into
hyper regulation especially on the left
people like Elizabeth Warren this is the
villain that they needed you know he he
is sent from Mount Olympus and they want
to not only destroy him they want to
destroy crypto which sucks because it is
going to bring in a whole new wave of
Regulation and you even have the
European Central Bank saying that crypto
and Bitcoin is on the road to
irrelevance what do you say to doubters
like that who are cheering the dip right
now
well look definitely this is going to
set the industry back years people have
lost a lot of confidence in
cryptocurrency simply because of what
has happened but I would say do not
worry mainly because this isn't an issue
about cryptocurrency this is an issue of
human corruption human error and human
greed that's simply all it is that's why
these conversations are so important
because we have to um give education and
actually teach people we do not want
them leaving their cryptocurrency on
these centralized exchanges particularly
exchanges that have been working so
closely with the SEC for the last six
months and somehow the SEC had no idea
that this company were insolvent that's
another story so we want to teach these
people that actually they can buy their
crypto on the centralized platform for
them remove it and take self-custody put
it in a non-custodial wallet where only
you hold the keys and no matter what
happens it doesn't matter what happens
to a company if it goes insolvent you
don't have to trust a centralized entity
all you do is you trust the blockchain
and that's the best thing to do and
excuse me it's set up for a reason and
it's actually like it's it's very
beautiful philosophically and in
practice and it's sad that it takes one
person to destroy uh the perception so
quickly and and so completely so what do
you tell people right now
um who are either thinking about getting
out completely what do you tell people
who have never gotten in is this is this
actually secretly a great time to uh
start investing in some crypto and
buying up some Bitcoin
yeah absolutely
um you know these bear markets are just
opportunities where some of the greatest
wealth is built but what I will say is
to focus more on bitcoin that's the one
which is the safest it's the only
cryptocurrency which is truly
decentralized Buy on those centralized
exchanges but remove it take
self-custody and actually what I want
people to realize is now is the most
important time because censorship is
Rife we're seeing people um have their
bank accounts Frozen for saying the
incorrect thing PayPal are finding
people for so-called misinformation and
so we do not want to have a centralized
entities having any form of control I
mean you mentioned the um European
Central Bank but it was actually the EU
that confiscated people's life savings
in Cyprus back in 2013. um they actually
confiscated people's life savings and
people woke up one day with absolutely
nothing left so the idea here is we do
not want to trust our money with these
institutions we're central banks with
governments we want to hold Bitcoin in a
non-custodial way and that is how you
can be a true sovereign
Leia thank you so much I hope to talk to
you again
thank you so much for having me Canada